the rat is a social animal you know
burrows
from which highway systems are
constructed and along which they meet
their associates
they seek food and company and quench
their thirst in company
and reproduce in aggregates our
familiarity with the rat is usually
based upon its living and close
association with humans we shall however
be interested in the rats own home life
in the behavioral maturation of a young
rat until it becomes an adult integrated
into the rat society this film was
compiled over a six-week period it was
taken at towson maryland when a quarter
acre tract of land surrounded by a rat
proof fence within this pen the several
colonies shown in this film were
observed for 27 months individual rats
were marked with numbered aluminum tags
inserted in their ears they were also
marked for site identification by
removing patches of fur
let's construct burrows which form their
major locus of orientation excavated
dirt forms arc like mountains trails
connect neighboring burrows as the
underground tunnel system enlarges the
surface becomes one fused mount when a
1/3 of the mound of this burrow is shown
here entrance is about which there is no
excavated dirt occur toward the
periphery of the burrows note the rat
entering such a bolt hole radio
extension of tunnels which emerge to the
surface form these bolt holes departure
from burrow systems is frequently with
considerable caution
trails from burrows may lead through
holes and fences from which the rat can
proceed to its source of food let me
join other rats before it again returns
to its home burrow by way of the trail
way system rats structure their
environment in many ways including the
diluting of vegetation one of the
important ways in which rats structure
their environment is by plugging
entrances into burrows air a lactating
female is sealing the entrance with dirt
and rocks from the inside the sealing of
entrances is most frequently exhibited
by lactating females no social rank also
contributes to the increase in frequency
of ceiling burrows after completing her
job the female comes out and inspects
her handiwork other rats which might
have entered and approached her young
passed by
a single entrance may be used by several
rats as the four rats shown here
indicate a female begins to modify this
situation by plugging this entrance with
grass her work is soon taken over by a
male note how this rat pulls on the
grass with both teeth and four feet and
that the four feet are used alternately
as in the overhand pulling of a rope
several rats immediately inspect the
recently plugged entrance
sticks are also dragged over burrow
entrances where they form a partially
effective barrier rats are continually
altering the appearance of their
environment annoying on wooden objects
they are agile climbers frequently trees
at night become festooned with rats
the tail assists in balancing
manipulation of food forms a major
category of manual abilities food
objects held in the four paws are
rotated as eating progresses when the
objects cannot be reached with the teeth
they are raked toward the rat with the
four feet
self manipulation as in this cleaning of
the tail frequently occurs included in
self manipulation is the grooming of the
fur
the structuring of the environment bar
rats produces situations in which social
interaction is increased trails are one
such situation trails connect goals they
lead from the burrow to the source of
food they connect adjoining burrows
increased contacts also occur for trails
from burrows converge and pass through a
barrier as at this fence the structuring
of the environment makes it easier for
young to orient between goals note how
this mother is followed by one of her
young
trails enable month-old young to find
water at some distance from their homes
there to meet strange adults
on the long course of maturation and
integration into society
the rats first associations are with its
mother she delivers them into the world
naked blind and helpless they would not
long survive without their maternal care
by two weeks of age there are Welford
but their eyes have just begun to open
they rarely venture out of the nest
it is also during this period of life of
the young that the mother is
particularly aggressive in driving away
any other rats which approached that
portion of the Burrow where her litter
is located
she even repels the dominant male of the
entire colony of 150 adults as he
approaches from the right
or in this case she nips a male who
attempts to invade her burrow between
two and three weeks of age initial
explorations within the Burrow are begun
however if the young venture forth
particularly if they get outside the
Burrow the mother will retrieve them
up to 21 days of age their only contact
with adults is usually with their mother
by the time they are 23 to 25 days of
age they are quite active make
independent excursions within the
borough and in its immediate vicinity
but even here they frequently remain in
close association with their mother the
four to five weeks old rat is
characterized by hesitancy in leaving
its burrow and by dashing motions to and
from burrows these scenes illustrate the
utilization of pre-existing trails by
juveniles this hypersensitivity of the
third of five weeks old rat is also
exhibited at a source of food it
encountered for the first time
it finally obtains a piece of food and
runs away with it here again is the
dashing movement by a juvenile in food
procurement note the five weeks old rat
drinking under the drain spout he dashes
away upon the approach of an adult the
beginnings of social adjustment are
visible in these scenes of the five
weeks old rat upon its first approach to
the source of water each time an adult
approaches it darts away this is unlike
the behavior of adults who much less
frequently avoid the approach of another
adult note how this juvenile rat reacts
to adults whom he is first encountering
at the source of food he darts about the
periphery of the group and runs away
each time an adult approaches the adults
show much less avoidance of each other
despite a rapidly dwindling food supply
by the time the rent is nearly a year
old it may actively compete over some
restricted goal as these two males are
doing over scent left by an estrus
female most encounters between adults
are relatively Placid
the most common behavior is nose
touching
two individuals approach cautiously and
nearly or actually touch noses following
recognition each individual goes its own
way or the one of lower social rank
merely retreats on guard or boxing
behavior may be exhibited by one or both
rats in an encounter
a rat which is stationary were
frequently run away from a rat in motion
yep throwing is a form of threat
exhibited by dominant rats
strike with their fellows accentuates
the caution frequently exhibited in
departing from the borough and upon
returning they dart back in caution is
also exhibited along trails
caution is the prime characteristic of
rats as in approaching the food source
beyond these steps or incoming through a
passage which necessitates their passing
near the Burrow of more dominant rats or
in approaching a strange object as these
traps strange noises as the rattling of
paper by the rat entering the garbage
can
causes withdrawal as by the rats on the
left
this particular burro system and its
radio extensions housed 13 females most
of whom had litters they formed the
harem of the most dominant male of the
population this dominant male may be
recognized by his crumpled hairless left
ear at the food source or by a burrow
hole he roams above his harems burrow at
will he guards the passage through the
fence near his burrow rats living on the
opposite side of the fence must pass
through it to obtain food
after one sneaked past him there is
elicited this dirt pushing which has
erotic implications and may be exhibited
by dominant males following aggressive
acts
finally he blocks the passage with his
body as males approach this passage he
assiduously chases them away
only after the dominant male dick parts
can these rats whose home is farther
from the food supply go back and forth
undisturbed
males who have contended unsuccessfully
possessed much scar tissue and often
large open wounds note the two males to
the left
such males are frequently forced to live
and exposed suboptimal Harbor ages as
under this ladder
although the dominant male was
aggressive about his home burrow he
rarely exhibited aggression at the
source of food here is the central rat
in the garbage can
the securing of food and weather
consumes a large part of each rats
nightly activity water may be lapped up
directly or it may be secured by dipping
in the fourth wall and licking off the
water or do may be licked off of grass
when the water supply is ample several
rats may drink together with little
antagonism when the food supply is ample
little antagonism is exhibited at the
source
even though rats from different local
colonies associate there at a source of
food which is ample but restricted and
availability
there is usually pushing and mild
threats little antagonism exists among
rats and an ample and readily available
food supply food is continually being
removed and transferred it rats of 35
days of age and older transfer food a
single individual may make many
consecutive trips most of the food is
taken to the rats home burrow
as the food is depleted though rats
aggregate at the food source even so
fighting such as occurs in territorial
defense rarely occurs the characteristic
behavior is an increased irritability in
the form of more frequent threats
fighting may occur as over this last
piece of palatable food a crust of rye
bread prior deprivation of water for 48
hours Foster's large aggregates there is
a marked increase in irritability and
the frequency of threats social rank
influences the ability of maintaining
position at the water
males are attracted to the scent of
females in estrus males inspect and
follow females
the female leaves sent at the borough
entrance over sticks and on the ground
note the feces the scent of the estrus
female forms a signpost the male drags
his genitalia over the sticks gnaws upon
them and saturates his fur by rubbing
under them males inspect the scent about
the Burrow entrance a male drags his
genitalia over a scent post
rocks become set posts earth saturated
with estrus scent is each other females
compete over the priority to inspect the
scent though they are members of his
harem this male approaches with caution
as one of the females also rubs against
the passage through the fence
the predominant pre copulatory behavior
elicited by the estrus scent is erotic
rolling about thorough entrances
the estrous female may remain just
inside the borough entrance the male
rarely enters after her and then only
momentarily
sexual rolling apparently may elicit an
orgasm at least the penis is cleaned as
after copulation the receptive female
spends considerable time above ground
the male cleans its penis following
mounting note the raising of the pelvic
region by the female the male sometimes
falls over the female after being
frequently mounted becomes antagonistic
toward males the stress experienced by
the female is aggravated by many males
joining the pursuit
as soon as one male descends another
moans she finally escapes when she
emerges the pursuit again ensues such
intensive pursuit only exists at
colonies lacking a clearly dominant male
tension also develops between males such
chases last many hours this is in
contrast to those colonies where a
highly dominant male protects his harem
from such stress as the night wears on
the antagonism of the female toward
males increases as also does the tension
among males when females do manage to
reach the water males prevent them from
satisfying their needs
in such colonies having an unstable
social structure the females have a
lowered rate of conception despite much
copulation and even those which conceive
rarely rear their young
in the past scenes we have shown some of
the behaviors exhibited by rats as well
as a few of the situations in which
these behaviors take place even so it is
apparent that the life of this so-called
lower mammal is quite complex